again
good
I was threatening to sing but nobody
took me seriously
okay well it will come if you think
there will be some movement for sure
welcome everybody to the afternoon
session and we'll continue with our
quick boot camp with parikshit telling
us about relations between
multicolibration and loss minimization
thanks Zoomer uh can everybody hear me
okay sounds good
okay usually when something runs for
five days and it features a lunch break
and a break for coffee and tea and it
features somebody with my accent
speaking very excitedly on the
microphone it's a cricket match but
and you know after lunch and day one is
when the heat sets in the lunch sets in
it's time for a siesta so I won't hold
it against you if you fall asleep but
you know just to stay awake feel free to
interrupt ask questions criticize my
notation laugh at my jokes make your own
jokes it's all good I have slides where
I don't need to get through all that
Frameworks so I'm happy to stop and
answer as many questions as they might
be I'm going to talk about multi-group
fairness and loss minimization as
promised and the motivating question
here is that Michael talked about these
Notions of multi-group fairness right
and as we've seen
these Notions they basically Place
certain constraints on the behavior of
your predictor under certain conditional
distributions and these conditional
distributions need to be carefully
chosen
but one thing which you won't find here
is any explicit notion of a loss
function right on the other hand the ml
models that we see all around us and
which are used day to day are explicitly
trained to minimize the loss function
so the question which motivates us today
is to ask how do these two worldviews
relate to each other right this placing
constraints in order to ensure various
multibook fairness Notions versus this
loss minimization viewpoint
now Michael of course gave you some
preview of what's to come here but let's
pretend that you know I didn't say
anything about this and there's some
real tension here about whether there's
some kind of a trade-off perhaps between
loss minimization and these multi-group
friends Notions
okay so
um we're going to talk about predictors
just like Michael did in a stock and
just as he said they are indeed
functions from a domain X which give you
probabilities for every Point there's
going to be a joint distribution here D
on points and binary labels we'll call
this nature
the moment you have a joint distribution
like this mathematically at least you
have this notion of a base optimal
predictor P star which for every point
it gives you the conditional probability
that the label is one now as Michael
said this could be something in our
heads this is nature you know we don't
make any assumptions about this for all
we know this is actually a Boolean
function deterministic right like you
know we will never be able to tell
because all we see is random samples
from this distribution
okay so this is the base optimal
predictor and the predictors that we'll
try and learn are just some other
functions speed tilde which assign
probabilities to every point and P tilde
of X is meant to be our estimate for the
base optimal predictor
so to draw a picture here this is the
space of all predictors it is a convex
space because you know if I have two
predictors I can do convex combinations
of them and that's another predictor it
may not necessarily be a good one but at
least it is a predictor right so and we
like convex sets because they are easy
to optimize over and so on
now the star of the space the pole star
which Michael the great foresight called
P star in a stock is the base optimal
predictor right it is the notion of
ground Truth for this particular
distribution
and the goal of learning at a high level
is to come up with some kind of
tractable approximation to P star now
the point here is that we're not making
any assumptions about nature it could be
incredibly complicated there might be
complexity uh computational and
information theoretic reasons why you
can't really learn P star itself right
so what we'll try and do is to come up
with some kind of practical
approximation to free star
and the main version we have in our
Arsenal for doing this is loss
minimization right you fix a Class C
which has a nice tractable description
fix a loss function and then you find
the model in the class C which minimizes
this loss the okay since this is going
to be so Central to
everything we talk about even though
you've all seen this before I'm just
going to take some time to set this up
with uh some detail right
so what is the loss minimization
Paradigm it involves three ingredients
there's a distribution D on points and
labels
then there is a class of hypothesis C
which I'm going to Michael talked about
functions from X to the interval 0 1
I've written -1 oh I've written minus
1.1 it is meant to be -1 comma one the
interval minus 1 1 and I'm going to be
very loose about this sometimes they'll
be they'll generally all be bounded but
we won't worry about what exactly the
range is okay
and finally you have a loss function
in my way of defining loss functions
they have two parameters t one is the
label Y which is a binary label the
other parameter T let's call it the
action this could be a real value more
often than not these will be
probabilities in the range 0 1 but we'll
just Define it in Greater generality
right so we have these three ingredients
you have a distribution a hypothesis
class and a loss function
and then what loss minimization tries to
do is to find the hypothesis in this
class C which minimizes your expected
loss the expected loss under D of l y
comma CX just to check everything type
matches because we are allowing for real
values here and CX is real value
but this is a very deceptively simple
Paradigm which you know it's extremely
powerful just look all around us
and a particularly important class of
losses are convex losses so what are
convex losses these are loss functions
where for every fixing of Y which means
for y equals 0 and Y equals 1 what you
get is a convex function in terms of
this parameter t right
if the loss is convex and your set of
predictors is also convex then loss
minimization is in fact it's you know
probably it's a tractable problem
so now some common loss functions which
we are all familiar with let's just
classify them into two broad classes
proper and non-proper losses proper
losses include things like squared loss
and cross entropy loss the defining
property of a proper loss is the
following if I know that Y is actually
going to be sampled from the Bernoulli
distribution with parameter p
then in order to minimize my expected
loss my best strategy is to say p here
right so in that sense it's proper or
truthful
on the other hand we also use non-profit
losses sometimes the simplest example
perhaps is the L1 loss where the L1 loss
on y and p is the absolute difference
why is it non-proper well if Y is
sampled from a Bernoulli distribution
with parameter 0.7 your best strategy is
to say one if it's bernalia 0.3 you say
0 simple exercise
logistic loss is another loss function
where if the true label is going to be
one you want to say plus infinity if
it's going to be 0 you say minus
infinity if you think it's half and half
you say zero right so there's a large
number of loss functions out there in
non-proper losses if Y is sampled from
Bernoulli with probability p
the best action now is just some
function of P but it may not be the
identity function anymore it could be
rounding P it could be doing something
exotic right
okay so with this background let's go
back to our original thing that we said
the whole goal of learning is to
understand the base optimal predictor
better and that loss minimization is
just a path to this end so in what sense
does loss minimization help us
understand the base of the new predictor
well firstly let's imagine that we
actually knew P star somehow P star
happened to be simple or we just got
lucky
now loss optimization it's you know it's
a breeze you can optimize loss for any
loss function in the world doesn't need
to be convex doesn't need to be anything
pretty much
why is that well given a point x you
know that the label is being sampled
according to the Bernoulli distribution
with parameter P star X
and we just said that when this happens
there is a best action you can take
which is this function KL this post
processing function compose that with P
star X just by the definition of this
function K sub L this is the best thing
you can do right
in other words what we are saying is
that this composition of KL with P star
is the best hypothesis you could
possibly have it beats everything else
but this is an extremely strong loss
minimization guarantee and we felt like
it deserves a name because it wasn't
clear that it had one right so in terms
of a notion which I will describe it
I'll Define formally at some point we'll
say that P star is an LC omnipredictor
for all Airlines it just means that it
can minimize any loss better than any
hypothesis you could possibly come up
with
okay great so of course if you knew P
star you can do loss minimization but
this is you know this is It's a good
thought experiment it's not telling us
anything about practical loss
minimization because we only minimize
over some fixed family of predictors and
you know it's uh it's very unlikely that
this is going to contain P Star right
so in this setting how is loss
minimization providing us a path to P
star
well it turns out that when you are
minimizing proper loss functions there's
a very concrete geometric argument which
supports this intuition
minimizing a proper loss over C is
equivalent to minimizing something
called a bregment Divergence between P
star and C basically the optimal point
in C will be the point which is closest
to P star in terms of this bregment
Divergence
yeah I've been cooked glass seat in the
bounded range but the scale may not have
longer doing yeah who's seen anything
but here
sorry I was going to say something about
chair Divergence yeah you're you're
making a good point here and we need to
make some assumptions that care doesn't
you know uh produce crazy values and for
most loss functions it won't right like
you can assume that these are the kinds
of technical details I hope nobody in
the audience picks onto but you know the
Simon senior scientist is here to make
sure that the stuck
uh is uh yeah it's a great question and
the answer is that yes that's an issue
and you have to work carefully but every
loss that you can you can assume that KL
has it may not be bounded in minus one
one but it still can be bounded
reflection
okay speaking about kale the reason I
was confused is that the care is a
fantastic example of bregman Divergence
just like squared laws right so when
you're minimizing the proper loss what
you're doing is actually finding the
predictor in C Which is closest to P
star in terms of this pregnant
Divergence brain wind divergences are
not exactly like distances but you know
for the purposes of the stock you can
think of them as distances right
so this is nice this is a really clean
geometric explanation for you know why
loss minimization gives you an
approximation to P star the only problem
is that if you change your loss function
you've changed the geometry of the space
so now a different point in the set
might be the optimal approximation right
so each loss function comes with its own
bespoke geometry and it will give you
maybe a different predictor right
when you talk about non-proper losses
there is no such clean geometric
characterization at least that I am
aware of but I am no expert here it's
very intuitive to say however that when
you're minimizing a non-profit loss you
still have to understand something about
the base optimal if you want to do well
with regard to loss minimization just
because the optimal is as you've seen
very closely tied to the base Optimum
predictive
so in this sense loss minimization is a
very concrete and you know it's a very
concrete way to think about
approximating P star
but still it leaves you with some
feeling that each loss is just telling
you some part of the picture by
minimizing a certain loss you get a
hypothesis which is good at
approximating P star in some way you
change the loss you come up with a
different predictor which approximates P
star in some other way every loss is
giving you like one small piece of the
big picture and there's nothing in the
loss minimization Paradigm which tells
you a coherent way to put all these
pieces together and come up with one
good Global approximation for the base
Optimum predictor
so this really is the starting point for
us this is the notion of omni prediction
no he doesn't because the geometry
changes when you run linear regression
right you get the predictor which
minimizes the squaredness I encourage
you to try this actually it's very easy
to do in something like psychic you do
logistic regression you'll get a
different prediction which minimizes the
logistic loss and so and uh this could
be very different things you know so a
picture would be you have this convex
set each loss defines a certain
direction right so you kind of find the
point which is optimal in this
particular direction different
directions take you to different points
there's no reason why uh
different losses will give you different
options
in some Metric space the loss defines
some direction yeah yeah I mean it's a
formal it's empirical it's everything
otherwise we wouldn't have these
different algorithms like logistic
regression and linear regression and so
on right and
um yeah that's actually where this stuff
is heading there wasn't there's no
reason to take these questions
different losses give you different you
know it's very simple examples
so what is forming prediction comic
prediction is a notion which provides a
uniform a unified thought to be start
it's a notion of simultaneous optimality
for a family of loss functions right
and
the main
the main to give away the punchline of
the stock what we're going to talk about
is how you can get Omni prediction from
multi-group fairness Notions the ones
that Michael talked about earlier this
morning
and then we're going to ask well this is
kind of bizarre why did multi-tube
fairness show up in a setting where
we're just talking about minimizing loss
functions is there some inherent reason
for this are there reverse connections
between Notions of only prediction and
multiply fairness
and along the way as uh you know as
advertised you'll see a bunch of
connections to Notions like outcome and
distinguishability internal and swap
regret from online learning and agnostic
learning
all right so
um if there's no questions at this point
let's dive into what an omnipredictor is
so this is uh based on joint work with
uh but
rheingold Woody reader who are all here
today and Adam kalai who's supposed to
be here and I was looking forward to it
because this is pandemic work so this
would probably be the first time that
the authors are all in the same room
together
uh but let's see so what is an omnip
predictor so there are two parents there
are two parameters here there is L which
is a family of loss functions and C
which is a hypothesis class
so an LC Army predictor
it is a predictor such that for any loss
in this family l
the expected loss you suffer when you do
the the optimal post-processing of your
predictions
is less than the expected loss suffered
by any hypothesis in C including the
single best hypothesis
if you're bothered by the scale thing
let's just think about proper losses
pretend that KL is the identity function
so now this is exactly the thing that
samega was asking for it's one predictor
which does as well as the best
hypothesis in C for any loss from this
family
um
so what is really the what is the Crux
of this notion the Crux of this notion
is that on the left this omnipredictor
we just learn it once at that point we
do not know what specific laws we are
going to be asked to minimize beyond the
fact that it belongs to this family l
so we have our data we do our learning
then we are done
on the right hand side though we are
comparing against the best hypothesis in
C which could be tailored to that
particular loss in fact if you want to
use the toolbox of convex optimization
every time you have a different loss you
need to solve a different convex problem
because really the Optima might be
different right
so we learn once for all of L after that
all we care about is the only reason to
know about L is to know what
post-processing to do but our
predictions have been made we just need
to know should I round p should I do
something else with it right but we are
able to compete against an algorithm
which could be tailoring C to the
specific choice of loss function l so
that is what is the power of this notion
um okay
it's a powerful notion but uh do you
have a question of issue
's earlier question asked this is by
definition
right
uh yes I mean not it's very likely to be
an entrepreneur I
I
but it seems very likely that it should
be
oh no we know such omnip predictors okay
I think Abhishek is making an important
point which is that we're not going to
restrict a predictor to belong to the
class C so this is typical in agnostic
learning this is what we call improper
learning that you compete against C but
you can allow yourself a bit more
computational power
so do these creatures exist well we've
already seen the answer to that P star
is an omnip predictor for all lnc so the
real question here is of efficiency but
computational and Sample complexity
theoretic can we efficiently learn from
the predictors for Rich classes of L and
C right so to just set some baseline for
what we should expect in terms of the
hardness of this task let's ask what
happens in the case when L contains only
a single loss like say the squared loss
right now we are exactly in the setting
of agnostic learning for C with regard
to some loss function l so this notion
that we're proposing is at least as hard
as agnostic learning and so if you're
not able to do even just agnostic
learning for C it seems very unlikely
that you'll be able to have omnic
prediction
so is the notion clear
yeah
all no slack factors just to make the
talk simple there are slack factors and
I'm sweeping them under the carpet yeah
but there is some Alpha here also
okay fantastic
so now I'm going to make this very
abrupt segment into multi-accuracy and
multi-calibration which are these
multi-grip fairness Notions which
Michael did a great job of explaining so
I you know he also was kind enough to
use almost exactly the same notation but
just to remind those of you who may not
have been here this morning
a predictor is C Alpha multi-accurate if
no hypothesis in C has correlation
alpha or more with the residual function
the residual function is the labels y
minus the predictions P hat look at the
correlation between C and these residues
if this correlation is small then your C
Alpha multi accurate
C Alpha multi calibration is the
stronger notion where you measure
correlation conditioned on a particular
prediction value fix a prediction value
like 0.7 measure the correlation and now
you take the expectation the outer
expectation is over the distribution of
predictions
okay so I this is great I don't need to
say anything about this because Michael
already did such a nice job of it this
notion as you've seen is efficiently
achievable using a weak agnostic learner
for C and of course it doesn't
explicitly mention loss anywhere
but the main result in this work I think
the main contribution of course is the
definition of omnip predictors which is
a notion which it's very natural the
main result is that if p is C
multi-calibrated
then it is an omni predictor for L
convex comma Lin C what is L convex it's
the set of all convex lip ships loss
functions this is pretty much every loss
function that we care about in machine
learning right Lin C is just linear
combinations of C it's all combinations
of the form summation Lambda ICI now in
reality I should bound the L1 Norm of
this combination but you know for the
stock I will not do that
so if p is if a predictor is C
multi-calibrated it is an L convex Lin C
omnipredictor where L convex is the set
of all convex loss functions
okay so when you see a theorem like this
maybe a good exercise to do is to ask
you know what is this really telling us
is it telling us something interesting
like what are we are talking about
binary loss we are talking about binary
labels so are there really a number of
interesting loss functions out there and
interesting algorithms for them that we
are able to compete against
well let's list some of them if you
wanted to minimize squared loss which is
of course convex and nice you'd do
linear regression L2 regression if you
wanted to do L1 if you wanted to
minimize the L1 loss instead of the L2
loss you'd write a linear program for
that why might you want to minimize the
L1 loss well there's this classic paper
of kalai clivans monster and it's a
video an agnostically learning half
spaces which made the point that L1
regression is often less noise sensitive
than L2 regression so there are things
you can do with L1 progression that you
cannot do without regression
if you wanted to do logistic loss you
run logistic regression
you wanted to do minimize exponential
loss you'd run AWS the famous algorithm
of freund and shapiri
I could go on and on well actually no I
don't know any other loss functions but
I'm I'm sure there's other loss
functions out there that people have
have thought about the point is now just
by running the multi-calibration
algorithm and then doing the right
process post processing you can compete
against each of these algorithms for
their chosen loss and you're doing at
least as well so that's the power of
this result
right
and also the statement is fairly tight
in the sense that convexity is important
here
you cannot multi-calibration by itself
does not imply omnipredictors for
arbitrary non-convex loss functions even
if they are electrons right so just what
I mean is that we have examples of
non-convex loss functions which are
nicely elliptions and so on for which
you wouldn't get an omnipredictor from
multi-calibration
right so this connection is pretty tight
are there any questions about the
statement
comment on YC here and Lindsay oh just
it makes it more powerful that's why you
know if I just said that I am doing a
weak agnostic learner you know I'm
assuming a weak agnostic learner for C
the power of something like beta boost
concept of taking linear combinations of
hypothesis right so just you know in
some sense there's no difference between
multi calibration for C and mincy one
implies the other with some loss of
times
interaction
uh no I am as possible about it as
anyone else so ask me this question
again because we're going to you know
I'll have I'll try and say something
about it I don't guarantee that it'll be
interesting or enlightening but we'll
say something more about it
yeah
it just takes a slower continuity or
something or because it's even more
positive
okay great I'll I'll show you a sketch
of the proof where you can uh you know
I'll tell you exactly where each of
these things come in and then maybe
there's other things you can do which
are bigger than lips
so I don't know but that's partly
because
so let's go through the proof and we'll
see
just because you know really the main
message here is not perfect it's really
about the statement but just because
this connection between multi-group
fairness and loss minimization seems to
come out of the blue I think it's good
to see the proof at least at a high
level to get some sense of why
multi-calibration even should enter the
picture here
so I'm going to do this proof under some
simplifying assumptions I'm going to
assume P star is Boolean just because it
makes it easier for me to draw pictures
I'm going to assume perfect
multi-calibration perfect
multi-calibration means that I don't
even allow an alpha error here I just
assume that for all prediction values V
of the predictor there is no correlation
between anything in C and the residual
function none of these are really needed
of course it's just to make our life
simple here
okay so let's fix a prediction value be
a loss l and a hypothesis C okay so I'm
going to show you an impressionistic
sketch of the proof okay so here is we
are focusing on the regions where a
predictor predicts the value 0.7 so this
could be a large set of points and since
the base optimal predictor is Boolean
the true uh base optimal for each point
is either one or zero so in some sense
Point wise a predictor is wrong
everywhere right it's saying 0.7 it's
saying I can't tell the difference
between these points they all look the
same to me
but because it's calibrated at least we
know that 70 percent of the time the
label is one thirty percent of the time
the label is zero right this is the
extent to which our predictor is correct
and that's all
okay now C is trying to compete against
this predictor and C of course doesn't
need to you know output just one value
everywhere right the whole advantage
that c has is that it can assign
different values to different points
if you're trying to for instance
minimize the squared loss you're hoping
that c is very close to 1 here and
closer to zero over here right so C gets
to Output different values on different
points right
but it turns out that actually see you
don't get that much of an advantage by
using a bunch of different values you
could just be using two values Instead
This is where convexity comes in this is
by Jensen's inequality
rights where the ground truth label is
one now the loss we pay is one fixed
convex function like one minus t squared
correct and now Jensen's inequality
tells us that instead of outputting a
whole bunch of values if you just output
the expectation of those values your
expected loss will be less so I can take
all these red values replace them by
their conditional expectation when the
label is one similarly I can take all
these blue values replace them by the
conditional expectation when the label
is zero right now notice that here I had
to condition on the label in order to
fix the loss function to be one
particular convex function I cannot just
you know replace everything by the
expectation
that by multi-calibration it turns out I
can it turns out that these two
expectations here they're actually the
same number which is the expectation of
C everywhere
and this is because of multi-calibration
multi-calibration tells us that there's
no correlation between C and the labels
y
and if these conditional expectations of
C were different condition on the label
being one and the label being zero well
it smells like correlation right and you
just you know you do the calculation and
it is exactly correlation so the fact
that multi-calibration means there's no
correlation exactly means that these two
expectations are the same they're just
the expectation of C
let me just finish this and we'll yeah
and uh naughty this is where the convex
the lipschitzness is important because
in general these two values they will
not be exactly the same they'll be close
together and then you want to argue that
by shifting these values to C you don't
change the loss function very much
[Music]
predictor has won because if you're
going to Output the same value at every
point in the space then from the point
of view of this predictor it looks like
the labels are being generated as
Bernoulli with parameter 0.7 because 70
percent of the time you see the label
one thirty percent of the time you see
the label zero so there is no better
single value than what the omnic
predictor outputs which is K sub L of
0.7 right
so that's um any questions
yeah but then this partition wouldn't be
multiplied
they make this argument for a
multi-calibrated predict so there's this
condition on somebody yeah condition on
the prediction value that's very
important there cannot be any
correlation between C and available
that's the promise
oh great so yeah it seems these for
convex sources you only use multi-f
remember actually see the condition on
the prediction that's the whole
difference between my the accuracy
yeah it's very important accuracy
wouldn't it
okay yeah good question
so so and I just want to make the
observation that we got a little more
than the advertised at first what we
claim this debt for all losses and C's
the Omni predictor will do better than
the hypothesis C right but if you look
at the proof carefully what we said is
let's fix the prediction value
now we can deal with any loss as long as
it comes from the family L any
hypothesis as long as it belongs to the
family C and conditioned on this
prediction value are omnipredictor is
doing better than this hypothesis on
this loss function so you could imagine
an adversary who comes to know what the
Omni predictor is going to predict and
then issues a challenge saying I'm going
to use this loss and I'm going to use
this hypothesis
doesn't help the Omni predictor will
still beat you right so this is a slight
strengthening I'm just going to observe
this and then you know leave this thread
hanging we'll come back to it at the end
if we have time to you know talk about
reverse connections and so on
so let's go back to our original picture
where we said that loss minimization is
giving us a certain path to
approximating the base Optimum but then
we said that every different loss
function is suggesting its own part
there's no unifying notion here
now I claim that Omni prediction and
multi-calibration are giving us such a
unified picture at least in the setting
of convex losses
because effectively what it's saying is
that you can find this one predictor P
tilde which is multi-calibrated
such that you should think of it as no
matter what loss function you choose the
shortest part from P star to C will pass
through P Trader right so it's this one
predictor which is simultaneously on the
shortest path from P star to C for any
convex loss function
and
um so yeah so P tilde it need not belong
to the class C but you know it's this
one predictor which is as good as
anything in C no matter what loss you
decide you care about
so this picture here it looks like slide
away right like
how many people have heard of slideware
okay I'm showing my uh the number of
years I've spent in corporate research
what is the most common programming
language out there
PowerPoint
slideware is software which lives on
PowerPoint and never you know migrates
to another programming language so this
picture it does look like slideware but
actually there is a formal theorem you
can exactly formalize this and you can
the language that you use is Pythagorean
theorems in bregment Divergence you can
actually prove that for instance the
square distance between P star and
anything in C is the sum of the squared
distances between P star and P tilde and
the squared distance between P tilde and
that predictor in C right so Russell in
the previous talk was asking this
question of whether for squared loss
this omnipredictor the multi-calibrated
solution could do much better than the
hypothesis in C the answer is yes this
is a measure of how much better it does
if it's far away from C it's doing much
much better
so great so what we've seen so far is
that multi-calibration it gives us the
strong notion of loss minimization
called Omni prediction for all convex
loss functions
uh and Omar likes to think about this as
a good karma kind of statement because
he swears to me that when they were
working on multi-calibration they had no
thoughts about minimizing any kind of
loss so the fact that it gives you a
really strong loss minimization
guarantee that's really nice and it's
really surprising it was surprising to
us
but this connection that I've shown you
is a little you know it's a little
fortuitous in the following sense what
if for some reason I decide that I care
about all losses not just convex ones or
what if I decide that all convicts
losses are you know that's too much for
me I just care about proper losses or LT
losses or maybe just L1 loss and L2 loss
right can I do anything easier than
multi-calibration for that this theorem
it gives us this one very strong
connection but it doesn't say anything
about the general notion of
omniprediction
and the other thing okay so the other
thing
is uh sorry
it's quite natural to wonder whether
this is indeed the right proof could
there be a simpler explanation of this
omniproduction phenomenon through the
lens of outcome and distinguishability
as Michael presented this morning right
the story that this predictor is
indistinguishable from P star
and P star is an omnipedictor so this is
an omnipredictor it's a very appealing
story right so could this be the real
explanation for what's going on you know
speaking not for my co-authors but just
personally for me any proof that hinges
on a clever application of Jensen's
inequality should be treated with a
great deal of Suspicion I constantly
live in fear that somebody is going to
email me and say Hey you had the
direction of inequality wrong but it
hasn't happened so far okay but these
are ample reasons these are all good
reasons to ask if there's a different
explanation for what we've seen here in
terms of outcome and distinguishability
I should mention that the connection
between outcome and distinguishability
and loss minimization was explored in
this prior work of Rod Blum and Yona but
they weren't coming at it from the Omni
prediction Viewpoint so they didn't ask
for just one predictor that works for
all loss functions like we will
let me check
the biggest thing I try
um okay so can we interpret
um this Pythagoras Theorem as the
following uh probably should be uh so we
can take the
Hull of all like you're very P star and
you are take these projections take the
Set uh set up all like you'll get
another contact set now if you do loss
minimization with respect to that comic
Set uh because with respect to proper
loss now you're projecting P star onto
that concept
I mean it's implicit I don't have an
answer to you but it sounds like a
fantastic summer project
so uh let's talk about it
is
no no no there are many many
multicoliberal characters of course
because like he started but I mean
somehow I thought that you said there's
it so so is there going to be a neat
picture that is closest to that gives us
you know it's a local multi-calibration
is kind of a local condition
there's no canonical multi-calibrated
predictor that we could okay
so there's like the ones okay
kind of to find a feature that it's
closest to see the one that like uh that
doesn't you know that satisfies I saw
that someone's using this Pythagorean
property no this Pythagorean property
that's what's kind of confusing about it
there could be many people does and
despite like anything between pizza then
start would satisfy but there's no but
but okay so there's no notion of like
most not that I know
yeah I would say more about it actually
but for any loss function there are
explicit forms you can write for it you
know it's as simple as the loss
basically right yeah the important thing
is just it's just a univariate
transformation you need to know nothing
about the data or the distribution
okay we're doing great so now let's talk
about whether there's an explanation for
this through the lens of outcoming
distinguishability
so outcome and distinguishability so
it's this beautiful work by dwark Kim
reingold Roth lamentiana where they
present a you know a fresh perspective
on this classic question of what does it
mean for a predictive P tilde to be
correct
and the answer which is very natural in
hindsight is that the predicted outcomes
of this predictor are indistinguishable
from nature
so this is formulated as Michael showed
us in the language of distinguishers and
the whole challenge that we have in the
OA model is to tell whether you are in
The Matrix or in reality right so the
you know nature is reality and the
Matrix is called the simulation
when you are in nature your labels y
star are being generated according to
Nature's distribution
the simulation is the world in which
your predictor P tilde is the base
Optimum so when my predictor says 0.7 I
actually toss a coin which is heads with
probability 0.7 and I output that label
right so this is going to be very
important throughout right that in the
simulated world we already have the base
optimal predictor it is our predictive
featured
so the distinguisher I'm going to allow
it to be a real valued bounded function
in the interval minus 1 1. we say that
the distinguisher wins if its
expectation under these two
distributions is different then it
managed to tell apart nature and the
simulation
if the distinguisher loses then the
predictor has one it's managed to fool
the distinguisher
so the main result in this paper was
that indistinguishability as we saw
relates to various Notions of
multi-group friend is I'm going to use
two restricted forms of this I'm never
going to give the distinguisher X the
prediction and the label all together
I'll give the label and one of these
other two things
in the model where you only show X and Y
to the distinguisher
indistinguishability is related to
multi-accuracy
the module that you only show the
prediction and why to the distinguisher
this is an incredibly weak model which
is probably the reason why it wasn't
considered in this original paper
there's not much you can do you're just
seeing a prediction value you're seeing
a label all you can do is check
calibration and that's the complete
notion of indistinguishability for this
model right if your predictor is
calibrated you cannot tell the
simulation apart from nature
this model seems really weak but if
you're interested in this question of
what is the right notion of calibration
how do we Define it in higher dimensions
and so on then this model becomes
important and if you're curious about
this I suggest you look at this upcoming
stock paper or talk to Lunge Yahoo which
who is here in the audience
okay so this is outcome in
distinguishability what you're going to
do now is try and see if you can come up
with an oi based proof of this notion of
omni prediction right
so the key the key objects that oi
studies are distinguishers so what we're
going to do is we're going to come up
with a family of distinguishers based on
lnc there's no suspense here Michael
showed us how to do this these
distinguishers will compare the laws
that c suffers on a particular loss L
with the loss the omnipredictor suffers
right on the same loss
only prediction is basically saying that
the expectation of these distinguishers
is positive or at least non-negative
under Nature's distribution
omnipreduction is purely a statement
about Nature's distribution it doesn't
care about the simulation the proof that
we just saw didn't make any mention of
the simulation
but this positivity Condition it's very
easy to prove in the simulation it's
easy to prove for the simple reason that
we know the base optimal predictor in
the simulated world it is the predictor
pitilda
now loss oi if we can enforce it will
ensure that these two that the
expectation of the distinguisher under
these two distributions is the same
right so that is what loss OE does given
a family of distinguishers it ensures
that you know a predictor which is Lost
Boy
uh ensures that the expectation of the
distinguisher under these two
distributions is the same if we can
ensure this we are done why are we done
the expectation is positive under the
simulation we said that this is easy to
prove we want Omni prediction which is
positivity of the expectation under
Nature's distribution and if these
expectations are equal one is positive
the other is also positive
so conceptually at least this is a very
simple and transparent way to get to the
notion of omni prediction
the question is whether this is actually
going to work right
um the point here is that we only wanted
positivity of this expectation that's
what omnipreduction is
but because we're encoding it in the
language of loss OE we're going to ask
for something stronger we're going to
say that these two expectations are
actually going to be equal so if this
expectation is 1 we want the other
expectation to be one if it's 0.5 we
want that to be 0.5 so we are enforcing
a much stronger condition than
positivity
okay so let's uh you know just Michael
has done some of this already so I just
you know give this this previous slide
it basically covers the entire idea of
what we're trying to do but let's just
go through it in a bit more of detail so
we're going to come up with this family
of distinguishers which Michael called D
and I'll call something else which
basically compare the loss that is
suffered by C on your labels so this is
what Omni prediction is right
omniprediction is saying that c suffers
more loss than my omnip predictor yeah
just to move this into the language the
last slide
positivity is something greater than
equal to zero yes yeah oh yes yes so
that's what I want right so we we
compared these two Expectations by
linearity I can write it as positivity
of a certain quantity
so now we have a distinguisher it's
exactly this it compares the loss of C
with the loss of the Omni predictor Omni
prediction is asking that the
expectation be positive when the labels
are generated according to Nature
what we do know is that the expectation
is positive under the simulation right
and this is very easy to see it's
basically because we have the base
optimal predict
loss oi will ensure that the expectation
of this quantities of all these tests is
the same whether you generate labels
according to Nature or according to the
simulation and therefore it will imply
on the prediction
so we are asking for something stronger
so it's you know it's not something we
know how to do but you know there are
all these equivalences equal which
equate y to a way some kind of
multi-group fairness so by working
through that you should get a statement
saying some kind of multi-group fairness
will give you only prediction
so that uh multigroup scientist
condition it turns out to be something
called calibrate and multi-accuracy
which is intermediate between
multi-accuracy and multi-calibration
so let's just walk through it right like
here's a test it has these two parts and
we're looking at the expectation of this
the natural thing to do is just say that
the expectation of these two parts
individually stay the same under both
distributions so you say that the
expected loss suffered by my Omni
predictor stays the same whether the
labels are generated by nature or the
simulation
you also say that the law suffered by CX
stays the same whether the labels are
generated according to Nature or by my
Omni predictor
this first Condition it's very easy to
get it comes from calibration because
it's an OE condition where the
distinguisher is only looking at labels
and predictions nothing else
the second Condition it's some kind of
multi-accuracy condition again because
we're not looking at the predictions
here we are only looking at the labels
and at the point x itself
now what multi-accuracy condition it is
we don't need to worry about that it's
something multi-accuracy for some class
which depends both on L and on C it's
not just dependent on C alone
okay that's good but is this going to
give us an interesting only prediction
statement right because the whole point
we wanted was independence from the loss
function
it turns out and I won't tell you
exactly how that yes it does give you
many interesting Omni prediction style
statements for glm losses so these are a
family of losses closely related to
proper losses they include linear
logistic loss squared loss and many more
things
it turns out that cpam actually doesn't
depend on L it's equal to C
so for this class all you need is
calibrated multi-accuracy which is just
calibration plus c multipuracy
so this is something intermediate
between multi-accuracy and
multi-calibration
and this has a very easy algorithm which
I won't tell you it's much simpler than
multi-calibration
for Lipschitz losses which may not even
be convex it turns out you can take C
Prime to be thresholds of C right so if
you don't care about convexity you just
have Lipschitz losses you can get
omniprediction even for those things
what you will not find here is a simpler
statement or an alternative proof for
the case of convex losses there's a very
good reason for that see
multi-calibration while it gives you
Omni prediction for convex losses it
actually does not give you loss oi this
is a stronger condition you cannot get
it just from multi-calibration
action
and in retrospect with the benefit of
hindsight I would say that this hope of
finding a different proof of that
statement through the lens of outcome
and distinguishability in my opinion it
was both technically and morally flawed
because convexity is crucial to that
statement it's not true if you allow for
losses that are not convex and in
indistinguishability you know there are
experts in the audience here I've never
seen any examples where convexity is the
thing which you know makes or breaks the
statement so
I'd welcome a different proof but I
don't think it's likely
okay so just to summarize to compare
loss oi and Omni prediction
omniproduction just compares
your omnipredictor with the hypothesis
in C as long as it does better you're
okay right so it's like these balance
scales here you can tell which is better
but you don't care by how much in Los oi
we replace this with a digital device
and we are able to measure exactly how
much the Omni predictor is better by and
now we want this to exactly equal what
we see in the simulation right no less
and no more so this is very natural if
you're thinking about it from the point
of view of indistinguishability of
course but therefore it gives you an
incomparable condition to Omni
prediction
it's a stronger guarantee but you also
pay for it in the sense that you might
need a stronger multi-group fairness
notion in order to ensure it
so I think I have about five minutes
left so now in these last five minutes
let me just ask the question we started
off with this notion of omnip prediction
which I think is a perfectly reasonable
Standalone notion and we keep running
into these various Notions of
multi-group fairness why does this
happen is there some inherent connection
between multi-group fairness and Omni
prediction okay
so a recent work by uh Omer Michael and
me it actually shows that there is an
equivalence this equivalence requires
one extra ingredient that's the notion
of swapping so maybe I'll just tell you
what these Notions are and Ben will stop
so what we show is that equivalence
between L convex C Swap omniprediction
and C swap multi-calibration the swap
notion they are inspired by the Notions
of swap regret from the classic works of
foster Vora and uh Blum Mansoor
so what is swap multi-calibration we say
a predictor satisfies C Alpha swap
multi-calibration
if the expectation of the max of a
certain quantity is small right so what
we're doing here is that for every
conditioning on the prediction value we
pick the best hypothesis from C right
it's not a single C that we compare
across all conditionings for each
conditioning we pick the best and we say
this should not exhibit too much
correlation
how is this different on the standard
notion basically we switch the Max and
expectation around
now if you're looking at this and saying
oh this is just some technical
modification to the definition and you'd
be exactly right that is what it is all
the known algorithms that we know both
of them they actually give you swap
multi-calibration right because uh this
is how they work you condition on a
particular value you make sure there's
no correlation
moreover even if this were not the case
the two Notions are equivalent of the
polynomial and Alpha factors when Alpha
equals zero they are identical
so for all practical purposes we can
consider these two Notions to be
identical right you'll hear more about
this in Rachel's talk later in this
Workshop
what is swap only prediction unlike swap
multi-calibration which is just a
technical modification of
multi-calibration swap Omni prediction
is a stronger notion it's the notion
that we already saw when we said the
proof gave us something more so here we
imagine sampling an X Y pair according
to Nature's distribution X is shown to
the predictor the predictor makes their
prediction
we then showed this prediction to an
adversary and the adversary is allowed
to choose a loss and a hypothesis to
respond to that loss which knows about
the prediction value B
and now the adversary suffers their loss
based on this hypothesis the predictor
suffers their loss based on the
omnipredictor we compare them
and we say that P is an LC swap
omnipredictor if it's still able to beat
every adversary of this kind
okay
so it's a probably stronger notion than
just standard Omni prediction right and
what we prove in this result is what we
prove in this work is that c swap
multi-calibration is in fact equivalent
to L convex C swap Omni prediction so
forget to swap here because they're
basically equivalent see
multi-calibration is equivalent to swap
omniproduction for convex loss functions
right so this is a characterization
why is this interesting well it tells us
that you know although you know they
said that they they said that when they
worked on multi-calibration they weren't
thinking about loss minimization they
lied right multi-calibration is
basically the same notion as a very
strong omniprediction notion which is
swap only prediction for convex losses
the other thing which is nice I think is
that it extends this view from the
classic work of Foster and Bora which
connects calibration with regret right
so Foster and Vora in their paper they
see a lot of very interesting and
intelligent things one of them is that
you can think of calibration as not
having swap regret for the class of
constant hypothesis so when I say point
three I don't feel regret that I should
have said point two instead in order to
minimize my squared loss
what this theorem tells us is that you
can think of C multi-calibration as not
having swap regret for the Richer class
of strategies coming from the class C so
again when I say 0.3 I don't wish that
I'd instead use maybe a decision tree of
some depth or a neural network depending
on what C is in place of my prediction
it wouldn't make much of a difference
foreign
so let me just conclude by summarizing
all these different Notions of omni
prediction that we've talked about we
started off with just the Classic notion
of omni prediction we introduced this
notion of loss oi and we said that this
is stronger than Omni prediction
we introduce the notion of Swap
omniprediction and we said look even
this is stronger than Omni prediction
and when you look at a picture like this
you wonder whether there's something on
top here there is it's the swap analog
of loss or I won't tell you what that is
but it turns out that this also has an
exact characterization in terms of
multi-calibration except that the class
C Prime now depends on the loss L as
well
what this picture tells us is that swap
Notions of omniproduction are very
tightly characterized by multi-group
fairness Notions so if you wanted to
know whether there is an inherent
connection between multi-grip fairness
and Omni prediction the answer is
definitely yes for the swap Notions
what this does not tell us is whether
multi-calibration was indeed necessary
for this omnipreduction result for
convex losses that we started with in
fact multi-calibration is giving you
something stronger it's giving you swap
only prediction so it's very tempting to
think that maybe if you don't care about
the swap aspect there might be simpler
ways to get it not that I know how to do
it but it's entirely plausible
right okay so I think I'm out of time
and I'm out of slides so it's a happy
coincidence uh what we've seen so far is
that omniprediction it's this natural
notion it turns out to have this tight
connection to multi-calibration for
convex losses
loss oi it's a notion of omni prediction
a stronger notion inspired by outcome
indistinguishability it's connected to
its own multi-grip fairness notion
called calibrated multi-accuracy
and we've seen some connections in the
reverse direction there's tight
connections between swath Notions of on
the prediction and some multi-grip
fairness Notions
so
um I'm going to skip this last slide
ahead let me just say that Adam is
giving a talk tomorrow which um you
should all attend it will be very
interesting I hope he's here
so in summary Mighty group fairness and
loss minimization the main subjects of
the stock they are intimately connected
not just to each other there are all
these nice connections to outcome and
distinguishability online learning
regret minimization and many other
things this is a very active area of
research there's new connections being
discovered and I'm really excited to see
a lot of these talks in this conference
I won't list them all out but you know
there's a bunch of them
and what is the general goal that we as
a community are building towards I think
the goal here is to have rigorous
interpretable and practical methods for
multi-group friends they need to be
rigorous because this is who we are as a
community they need to be interpretable
because as we've seen with differential
privacy users having trust in the notion
is very important
and um they need to be practical because
we do want to impact the world as it is
out there
so with that I just want to say that you
know the ideas that I've presented here
are uh you know they are borrowed from a
bunch of wonderful co-authors and
colleagues and I want to acknowledge
them all and thank you very much
there is a quick question
at Coffee breaks in half an hour we have
another
thank you